you got there because you put out great
content that people want to watch email
but let's take a step back
is that because you I mean obviously
even looking like what you're doing with
your look a tire is that because you
just love that stuff and that would be
cool like is that because you think
that's where the most money is like why
does that run through your mind well to
me but you can do a million so let me
give an example the reason I did the
case with steel is because my whole life
is predicated on buying older nostalgic
brands and remarketing them so adidas or
Nike would have been a pass for me
because that wasn't me resurrecting a
brand got it
so if Nike come along or adidas and
offered me ten times the money the case
whis offered me I would have said no
because for me my goal is eventually
turning my whole empire into buying
Cracker Jacks or sprite or Captain
Crunch and buying it for two hundred
million and selling it for two billion
that's what I want to do for a living so
when I ask you like why do you want to
do it when you say we have a huge
audience cool you could also go on tour
and make seven million dollars by Jay
being with somebody to put you on tour
to do that like you know to me if I
understand what now if you said I love
[ __ ] clothes and it'd be super cool
and my friends would think like that's a
great answer so to me it's you sure I'm
going yes to me I want to go high why
why because if it it's the [ __ ]
question yeah because once you
understand why like if the if the answer
is cuz that's what I perceive to make
the most money yeah well then I would
say okay let's take a step back let me
tell you how I think that would play out
remind me like what you're doing how
you're doing it so I think that's why
it's such an important question I love
video creation I love like that's me
that's what I meant
that to me that's what saved me I had
PTSD and went overseas anxiety and you
know I promise guys over there they're
like your funniest [ __ ] crazy doing
pranks you know I help them out over
there I was never out mm-hmm I was like
yeah I promise you guys I'll do it you
know no one came back a little [ __ ]
out PTSD and anxiety just didn't like
what kind of course and then I just kind
of like one day you said with your
fitness I just woke up and said [ __ ]
this assistant this isn't what I want to
do I want to create and that's when I
started making funny ass Facebook videos
started posting them up started catching
on and as I was building videos I'll
slowly helping myself loved having out
of it you know so for me to go to New
York even three years ago was not I
couldn't do it I understand and so the
video creation along with what you know
just life it just clicks
it's how I get all these fans yep I got
all these brands that are after me yep I
get it you know the reason you want to
promote other brands is cuz they pay
tens of thousands of dollars source that
would be the answer to your question yes
the question becomes how and what do you
want to do next it you know it's just a
very big deal here's let me tell you a
couple things that will probably make
you feel good now I'll get you guys
pumped there aren't that many things you
can do wrong let's start there you know
like I think you know watching people go
through this that you're going through
now this like holy [ __ ] and I listen
I've been doing this a long long time
like I watch people to live this on
MySpace so for me this is just the same
show over and over right what you could
do wrong is take it for granted of
course the only thing that influencers
right now that are popping are
vulnerable to is taking it for granted
the amount of kids that took mine for
granted
and we're lazy and now are sad and want
to be relevant again but are super
behind in an Instagram world you know
the people that took myspace for granted
or early Twitter like I've watched this
over and over so I think one of the
things that you have in your advantage
is
you're probably based on your age and
the limited I know about your background
already in a place where you'll probably
appreciate it more and grind harder
which is a humongous variable that's
number one I think you need look I think
this notion of like [ __ ] this like I'm
not gonna build up [ __ ] supreme I'm
gonna start Supreme is rad and like I
will never suppress anything but it's
about self-awareness like it's not that
easy to start a brand there's a lot of
infrastructure not that I'm against it
here's what I would say I'm a big fan of
stop starting slow so the first thing
you should give a lot of thought to is
is getting somewhat knowledgeable about
e-commerce in general right like
starting a Shopify store or something of
that nature no you're not I'm here to
look listen and help you yeah yeah so
basically like with the whole shop
buying stuff I what really hit me from
you is if you suck at are you [ __ ]
suck at it
you know yeah and you can hire somebody
that's what I'm that's like to me to me
when you're making these dollars now
like what do you you know I always say
this what are you doing with it
so of course I'm going back you know and
that's it that's yeah of course you want
to do you buying something with it but
like but like be thoughtful of like how
you're allocating to me well you know
it's what I did like these characters
didn't used to exist it wasn't me on my
phone like do you pour it back into like
a Sally sitting here in three months
when you come back and visit or a year
later and she was you know ahead of
EECOM for the you know for Dunkin Donuts
yeah cuz she lives up there you know
like that kind of [ __ ] do you know what
I mean yeah I think you have to think
about that and I'd also say I'm not so
sold that product is the right answer
other than if you feel passionate about
it and you think it is then that's great
yeah I just want to make sure that
touring more brand deals speaking
writing a comedy book like you know
going to a production company and trying
to do a Netflix special like there's
still a lot of things to talk about here
so my story in general I
and very influential and very outspoken
and I really pump people up kind of like
so for me it's like how do I even start
just going to get in front of people
like I would even like to go to
companies and be like listen you know
you guys are wasting your money on these
ads when so one of the ways you can do
that is literally one day instead of
creating the other way you create us
through bizdev and you know hustling and
I would email Dunkin Donuts and
Marshalls and Bose and but but I'm just
named three new england-based companies
you know to go very [ __ ] far yeah
right Reeboks up there everybody's
[ __ ] boss of Sam Adams like I don't
know centimeter but like if it's titled
like I think I can bring you value I'm
winning I over I have a million or a
close to I don't know what the numbers
are like followers on Instagram I think
your brands are miss playing it one out
of those ninety-seven people are gonna
be like come and then the second you
then have the ability say well I spoke
at Reebok it becomes [ __ ] like
dominoes it's kind of happening in a way
now I'm sure does song doing the trailer
for Paramount they're extremely pleased
they want to work more it's awesome yes
and they gave me 20 hours they literally
call me and say can this kid do it and
if they went through 9gag yes you know
it's what I do I love creating I think
do you have a sense so back to creating
your you know I think one of the things
that really worked out for me that I
always have that I have to do a better
job communicating on which is in
hindsight I was a creator and an
entrepreneur like the thing that you
know is playing out for me as I'm going
through a lot of this stuff is like you
know a lot of people like [ __ ] you're
[ __ ] really creative right like my my
creative team you know Ryan Harwood my
partner and the media publishing side
he's like I have meetings with you
because you're a creator you're creative
you know d-roc and and my team says it
so do you have a sense do you think
you're a good entrepreneur do you think
you can build a business well then you
got to just try you got to prove it to
yourself
I mean I think look I think the biggest
thing you need to be careful of is I
think people over stress themselves
thinking that they're in this remarkable
you know at one point I'm saying don't
take it for granted and now I'm about to
tell you like don't think it's that
remarkable that you become overstressed
that you like put too much pressure on
yourself
yeah for example if you continue to
produce content that people want to
watch you'll continue to have leverage I
think the one thing I would tell you is
do not become too reliant so tell me
what is going on with your platforms so
I know obviously you're winning on insta
so Facebook obviously we're talking
before just did a crash overnight I mean
they took everybody's reach just like
that seventy percent in serum to do the
same thing where are you on YouTube
where are you in your own calm where are
you on Twitter
so YouTube we have about 500,000 that's
where we put our longer form content no
Facebook we actually just received a
watch page which is basically what the
Facebook's going to be maybe 10 maybe
trying to at least we don't know they're
all over where are you on posting
organic on your fan page on Facebook
hope still normal we must do something
okay keep keep going you know see you
work how much were you community
managing on Facebook you post people
comment you jump in and reply to every
comment you're not doing on Facebook I
do I answer messages always on both but
you're not replying for the comments on
Facebook he does okay sometimes not like
I respected religious religious on
Instagram as much as you can on the
others yeah of course what about face
what about Twitter you need to go on it
I mean barstool is like living off of it
yeah like top literally literally you
should go to your hotel room tonight and
start up here like like create it and
make your first video but like Gary Vee
yelled at me here's my first one and
then you need to go to Instagram in your
story and be like I [ __ ] up I went to
New York area you yell let me go follow
me on my Twitter tomorrow because first
of all you can put
you put what I said 140 to 80 is it what
is it
it's more than 140 I think it's to it
but it's 280 seems weird but like you
put close to 3 minutes I think maybe
more videos you're making 1 minute
videos on Instagram here's my thing you
can't create friction for your audience
to 20 you can't create friction
what if somebody loves ya Twitter is
also a place where there's a unique
different thing there's like here's my
thing
this is it like this could be the rest
of your life like you can really win
this game well I get it you want it to
be yeah but I know that the economy is
gonna collapse eventually I know there's
gonna be a million people like supply
and demand of people that want your life
right now is every single person 13 to
22 every single but like but before we
go into of course I want to make you
leave with this right now in America and
that's not even counting global but
let's just stick with it if you are 12
to 22 your goal in life is to be an
influencer on social networks that is
your number one ambition that means what
you have behind you is 10 million funny
people who are gonna start off at zero
when you're not gonna be at zero anymore
it's just like boxing
somebody's gonna be more desperate than
you so I think that when you're in this
moment it's just inexcusable to not make
content everywhere you can out of what's
hot now you've already in your short
period of time lived winning on Facebook
and then losing organic drop like you're
basically like you need to be religious
on none of these [ __ ] platforms are
gonna have to leverage on me I'm gonna
create all of them do you know I could
give a [ __ ] which platform goes or not
I'm winning on all of them
got it you don't want to wake up
tomorrow with a headline that's when you
post something like why didn't we just
get a fifth of the views or likes that
were used to it's already happening on
Instagram of course yes you know anybody
who's creating every day knows it's
already starting to happen
everything sure that I think I think I
think you should start a podcast I think
you should right [ __ ] stuff on
LinkedIn I think you should [ __ ] you
need to squeeze the [ __ ] out of this
moment what you want to go get a job but
you understand and like at the you know
this paramount thing does I mean I think
you probably know this and I respect the
[ __ ] at a three job so I just excited me
it's a good [ __ ] but like very quickly
you could be back to nah
you could be at none I mean this can go
real fast well so to me it's like it's
like you're you're getting seduced by
the platform that you're growing on
course and then you get caught and of
course like you should have an email
list that you sent an exclusive video to
just there because that's what you own
that for life yeah diversification right
diversification
yeah and it's worth it right so what may
happen is you're like wait a minute I'm
actually gonna reply to ever half look
you only have 24 hours like even if you
you know like there's only so much you
can you know like it's smart to sleep
it's like you got your 18 17 you know 19
hours right so like you got to maximize
those I think diversify on your
platforms is extremely important it's
it's been the cliche biggest mistake of
influencers over the last decade they
get high and the thing that is winning
for them at the moment and then they
don't want to put in the work another
place like to me it you've lived it
already like why would you not be on
Twitter like if you like let's play it
out
like you said it's not sinister it's not
about you know I never think about what
I do
if somebody's consuming [ __ ] on Twitter
it's true I've seen my videos going
viral on Twitter that's why you slept
down here you didn't come here for my
good looks to came here to get some
[ __ ] [ __ ] this is [ __ ] I survived
[ __ ] that matters that's about YouTube
too I mean that might do an apocalypse
from 80% of home prices dropped
overnight of course there'll be ups and
downs it's these are networks
MBC's rolling when Seinfeld's on when
it's not it's not today Facebook's this
tomorrow tomorrow Facebook does why
Twitter does X Twitter was cold and
politics got it hot like snapchat dead
sure until tomorrow when snapchat
announces some crazy [ __ ] like [ __ ]
Princess Leia hologram shits and
everyone's like oh [ __ ] I should've been
paying attention a snapchat got it or it
becomes [ __ ] Friendster I don't know
I'm just not gonna [ __ ] allow myself
to be vulnerable no I mean I'm not
posting on tumblr anymore I made my
[ __ ] dirt on tumblr back in the day
fiddler was my youtube so absolutely not
but while there's still stuff going on I
do not you don't look you don't revive
something that's dead but sometimes
something that's sick rises like a
phoenix got it dead is dead it's not
just not dead
I still post every day on snap so great
still do the snap Instagram Facebook
YouTube good so you got add to it you
got a Twitter
um I think LinkedIn is tricky for what
you do though I think you could write
the occasional like how humor like you
mean like this may not even be up your
alley
so I'm not obsessed with LinkedIn for
you but I would say why corporations
need to take like whatever you want to
talk to corporations about that would be
a good LinkedIn post or you could write
something like your 3 minute escape
your desk at your Joe's remember the
thought you got always reverse-engineer
the psychology of the user so maybe you
do a whole series of like 60-second
laughs while you're at work like you
name them that you see where I'm going
or like not safe at work you know from
your buddy again you see where I'm going
you got to kind of give a wink to the
audience I mean my content on LinkedIn
like the pushback on cursing is extreme
because it's a professional place so
like cool I've got to make a decision of
like I said a team or like look we need
to start considering to censor on
LinkedIn because the audience is always
right I can't be like [ __ ] you yeah I
gotta be like I respect you the audience
is how you're making your money
paramount didn't give you money cuz your
looks
Peterman gave you money cuz your
eyeballs they're your currency and what
your thing is you're like you just want
to stop taking three [ __ ] jobs yeah
well then great that's awesome yeah but
I mean that would be a reasonable answer
like one of the reasons I'd be like [ __ ]
it let's do it full-time is like it's
more fun to do this and get paid but if
you love what you do like then I'm like
you know then I would be patient right
like how do you get it like you're only
four do many people who rip their arms
off like now you've been doing it on
Facebook for a while right yes Facebook
actually did the same [ __ ] when YouTube
died I get FML on Facebook in six months
out of ballistic look I think you
clearly have a Content comedic style
that resonates with people yeah I would
tell you that never goes away so you
know to me it's just about being
thoughtful the more [ __ ] detox tea
and dumb [ __ ] you do the more likely you
won't win so like the longer you can
wait I mean looking at the youngest [ __ ]
it's like you're gonna you're gonna
struggle for me giving you any other an
sort of like they will come if you came
building a [ __ ] audience right of
course that's how they came in the first
place like where do you think they came
from when you had 3,000 followers in
this room they weren't coming yeah
like they showed up when you started
have hundreds of thousands like it's not
super complicated and like when you have
four million more of them will come and
the numbers will be bigger just for me
like I see all these people that you
know that's the worst start to a
sentence ever okay like literally the
worst start to a sentence ever is but
for me I see other people no I see our
fans like I see the people that are
following us okay okay so Graham I'm
like we have you know a million people
following us if we sold a bracelet that
says Huey TV for one dollar to 1 million
people you wouldn't know that how many
people like that's not how I work I just
that's not the way it's gonna be
yeah that's first of all why don't you
have a million one views on every video
then yeah so you're getting more views
than your audience sighs yeah let's look
how many videos are you posting a day
will you just post three times a week
right now that's it yeah why because I
can only prank so much right I gather
name comedy we're getting into skips now
so that's definitely you know we typed
it up have you thought about mix that
makes sense now or your views it they're
sitting in your stream make sense but I
mean these are these are bonkers numbers
yeah like like yesterday's videos four
million no tricks
I mean all the endings are there it's
all real I just know I just can create
like a you just know what the audience
like you under your reverse-engineering
what you know is gonna work so I also so
I get a like do you know man Steve
Bartlett Steve Bartlett yeah Steve
Ireland my business partners Jeff Taylor
we both have 22 pages together as well
on Facebook and this is one way we found
how we went about going extremely viral
I post a video and we share across the
whole entire now yep a lot of people do
that yeah of course
so that's that's another thing that I
started get into so I also run those 22
pages as well but with the reach drop
you know it's kind of change
everything told us but like you said
we're just trying to kind of see what
Facebook's doing but I still I'm posting
the content on Facebook I'm still doing
the Facebook stories along with
everything else and luckily we just got
a wash page which is cool breezes
bonkers on that as well sure you've seen
he was like 7% of something and saying
because they're pushing that now so I
worked my ass off to get that and so
we're gonna be starting on that again
tomorrow it was just built and I got my
dot-com being built and I've been
dabbling in the e-commerce as well which
I'm just getting setting up the shop
doing like you said mm-hmm so I mean
right after I read your book I just went
[ __ ] crazy
I mean I'd live it I'm telling you I'm
not [ __ ] kidding you like I hit a
million to a million okay doesn't excite
me a million views doesn't excite me
either
no that [ __ ] excites me you know the
money of course is great but I don't
just focus on the money the money will
be there if you have to care about the
audience I'm the most good [ __ ] I know
my audience is just which is one reason
I'm scared like you said I'm not gonna
take this cheap aspiration no Oh which I
have not you know and in the long run
I'm doing what you said with the
patience I'm not gonna hold a [ __ ]
detox teas for a $500 shout out that's
the [ __ ] I don't use I think of the fans
what would they like if it fits my brand
I've turned down many that do not fit
not just cuz the money that they just
don't fit again you know my audience to
me is family us that's my [ __ ] it's also
the only asset you have Yeah right yeah
it's the only thing you up and like you
said I look for longevity I'm not gonna
sit there sound some [ __ ] I'm
looking for the long you know when I
possibly come up with the brand do
whatever I decide to do and these people
are [ __ ] die hard cuz I take two
seconds just a message of back and
they're like that's my [ __ ]
dude you know 100 thousand percent yeah
and that's what I'm Ricky Henderson roll
yeah yeah and I'm just
I believe in it tremendously it's I see
what do you mean as well like I just go
ballistic and it's just a connection now
it's like they know you or they met you
what are some a simple heart thank you
you know and I said Chris it's a bad
feeling of course and we are starting to
get into skits which I can't office kids
every day yeah what you know one of the
things I would tell you is I do think
there's a I do think there's a debate
for you to do like still images like I
think you should play a little bit
I I would tell you you getting a hundred
eighty thousand views on a video off of
the things that I'm seeing between 1/4
million and I'm saying this for a reason
is probably weirdly the best thing that
can happen to you I think one of the
things that's holding you back now is
the success of every piece of content
and I think it becomes crippling instead
of a positive attitude which is why this
kit made me feel so [ __ ] free when I
made this kit is it wasn't just a prank
I thought three I was telling you I mean
even just an occasional video of you
straight to your face and just saying yo
thank you
like just just mixing it up I mean I'll
be honest with you I just had a great
day too cuz I [ __ ] did I don't I
don't mix it up really either like I did
a a just a post of like looking in the
ever do this and the thing was I Easter
Egg the random person and just tagged
them and they've gotten [ __ ] they've
gotten like 1400 followers in the last
couple hours and like like just mixing
it up yeah just trying these matters yes
of ask it is something I recently just
did it's at a million and people loved
it and I really love the skits as well
pranks are fun but they get born I'm
just funny as [ __ ] it's how I am so to
speak you know and I want to get into as
well I mean it's perfect this we love it
we enjoy it my [ __ ] too edgy but you
know I try to keep it down a little bit
because of this but I'm just I mean look
the the edgy stuff is what it is like
you know yeah I remember one thing kid
uh um there's brands I'm not gonna [ __ ]
with you and then there's other brands
they're gonna come at you hard yeah you
know if American Pie the movie was
making a reboot like you'd get all that
paramedic you know what I mean so but I
love what you said - because diversify
industries' it's just it's also your
sense of humor yeah yeah like some
people are gonna be like Andrew Dice
clays Andrew Dice Clay like [ __ ] like
Richard Pryor's Richard Pryor like you
know like you've got like dude I [ __ ]
live in corporate America and curse my
face up we lose real business here of
course like but I also gain business cuz
of it like it's gonna be what its gonna
be like altering your truth is always a
bad idea
I'm with you I'm respected cuz I love it
I love that when you hear to Fox that's
it I feel like it pumps me up you know I
mean I want over-seasoned [ __ ] and
that's how I talk you know horse I don't
want to change like you know she's like
it's Gary Beach and rest sex is like
it's just not me I'm just this is what I
wear you know I just like them
I'm my own boss because I just like to
be what you know what I've got to do
this part right you get to like just be
yourself
well she just like second second well if
I look like her I look sexy to my guy
role look what you have like very basic
yeah you need to do your thing
like enjoy it here with her man you get
to do it your way listen I think that um
a couple things stand out I think a
couple things you need to think about
one it's early and like again in this
whole like you know like kind of like
I'm thinking Tuesday this is awesome
this is exactly what should be happening
it's not about neither one of you are
right these are the cup make sure when
you're debating these things there is no
right I think that's why we work well
too late
it's not about right it's about thoughts
I will say that selling stuff is a good
idea um but I don't think I to your
point I don't think a hammie brick I
don't think the bracelets at a dollar I
don't think the t-shirts what I would do
if I were you if you wanted to go
t-shirt which I always think is a fun
lightweight way to start I would look at
the content that worked and make
something that's an inside joke just to
your fans would be great you know and
that's it
no even ham you keep not even like I
believe when we put my cyclic I'm always
debating like when we like I have my
signature it's very subtle but even that
I'm like yeah like I think you have such
your own vernacular and your own meme
like viagra makes you twerk based on a
video that went real well for you is way
better than something anybody else could
say a lot of people could say fake or no
filter anybody can say that you you
rather so what people make the mistake
one so what the mistake you're making
right now is you're thinking with not
depth I would argue if you put up based
on what I've heard that viagra makes you
twerk versus something more generic
that's more accessible to most people
like you know no fillers sound like that
you would sell more the first and the
audience would be happier you did it
non-stop
that's cool yeah it's absurd and a lot
of times I use products in my video and
they contact right away ready to work
like what are these animals that I gave
her of course yours on a diet and that's
what your cookies yeah yes yeah just
like well you're coating them in yeah
you know that if you use the product
you'll hear from them 24 hours yeah of
course yeah yeah of course of course
look remember how you got there yeah you
got there cuz of Bute like I it's not
about that it's about you got there
because you put out great content that
people want to watch I think when you
make the transition to trying to make
this a viable business as you should as
they want you to your audience still
your audience wants a video every day
and if the andif and if you can afford
to do that they're thrilled like they're
not worried about you making money
they'll be fine just like look I don't
have the cliche things that all the
entrepreneurs have but I'll have like a
sneaker come out and like like to me my
big thing is that like I'm thrilled to
ask but I don't expect and I think that
the level of respect that I have for my
audience is no question the reason I'm
gonna sit at the top of the tree because
I'm different
I don't disrespect them I don't think
I'm smarter I don't like want to just do
a quick flip and all that [ __ ] is gonna
play out great and my favorite thing is
just coming to New York recently is like
oh yeah you made a video on like we're
driving we're on our way right there's
something there's something here you
guys are doing a meeting great yeah be
great yeah that's the best right even
look I wouldn't I think you're on the
right path here's what I would say more
and like the longer you can hold your
breath of course you're gonna start
daydreaming and getting excited about
like what this could be
just the longer you can hold out longer
you can hold out like you know you're in
the clouds in the dirt I'm still just in
the [ __ ] dirt I get it I get it and
I'll just keep going it's it's just I
love it so much the clouds part for
definition purposes is the why got it
yeah why and like you clearly love to
create and you would do this for free if
you could oh yeah I get it I get it I
get the same high I get it yeah when
something use like thought up yeah
what's better feeling that that's what's
fun being a greater right it's in your
brain and then you thought it would go
and it did it's the fact you can create
it and how many people saw like the
viagra twerk one 310 million people it's
absurd [ __ ] insanity it's absurd look
at the Superbowl numbers compared to a
video that I created that's true so and
a little trouble having now a true
discussion with 9gag is it's having
these companies understand the power we
actually have just wait yeah I was
telling 9gag I was like we're in 2020
because when they realize what you can
do you know
yeah it's a matter of time you got to
hold your breath as long as possible
it's as simple as that like get yours
along the way fine
nice trip to New York it's nice to buy a
nice jump suit that's fine but don't
like just be like create a scenario
where you can hold your breath the
longest you will win because the longer
you can continue to just purely bring
the audience value you're putting you're
putting things in the bank
the second regardless I hate when I have
a new book or a sneaker out means I'm
taking out of the bank you ask you can
say whatever you want about authenticity
and this and out you've there's asking
and there's giving my preference is
giving but I wanna I have my own
ambitions and things that nature
I mean it's Jab Jab Jab right hook and
like I always think that thank you
economy's the best book I wrote but I
love Jab Jab Jab right hook cuz it
absolutely articulates how I think about
it give give give give and then ask it's
okay to ask but [ __ ] like it they
wouldn't let me do this but I wanted to
call it Jab Jab Jab Jab it was like nine
jabs and then it was five and I was like
[ __ ] at three but nonetheless like the
more you could be in the jet like it is
fighting like you know super hard to
land right hooks if you keep throwing
right hooks and that's the mistake
people make cuz then once they get on
that drug of like making money that I go
my god but now you're starting to
decline yeah there's only two movements
up and down every time you ask going
down it will come it will come you're
already at a big audience you clearly
have a skill set it's worked everywhere
overseas for a bunch of guys on Facebook
than YouTube that it works get it as
many places possible and get your
content distributed as many places
possible meaning when all these mean
pages and other people want to use your
content the answer is always yes of
course because because they can't steal
your face yeah you're not making your
money on ads and commercials do you
understand yeah of course you want
everybody to take your content yeah IG
all the time just tag
tag me tag me attention is the equity
it's the asset yeah it's it's just even
the story views you know it's like
getting three hundred fifty five to save
you some kind of Holly's yeah I mean
dude your numbers are staggering yeah I
also tell you like yours you're like
getting way more like I've a bigger
following count but I don't have a
bigger audience yeah not an idea we've
started pumping out more you think
just don't get bored they just wanna do
it everything guys it's it's much more
simple than that it's like you put out
as much coffee as you can cuz if it's
quality I mean I wish biggie put out
eleven more albums it's just quality you
either have one video in you or you have
a million like I think the reason I'll
win is like I got a lot of my tank
because I'm good at social commentary
and the analyzing social behavior so I'm
gonna have a real good point of view on
augmented reality and machine learning
and cryptocurrency and VR like my [ __ ]
will never change that's what I'm good
at
if you can think I'm up in your dome and
make them viral forever it will work
yeah and the truth is they'll always be
another thing like a Viagra that you can
and at working that you can put together
and make happen it's unlimited once you
understand the psychology of what makes
somebody tick it's actually unlimited
cuz then you can use the cronut and
avocados or you can use kale chips and
pomegranates or you can use like or like
the like if you really expand your
universe or like if you start getting
into acting like the new girlfriend the
new boyfriend your best buddy on tour
like you should be [ __ ] yeah yeah
right the reverse when she gets you
right yeah
Neverending if you can create you can
create that's what I do all day like as
we want I get it
you watch yeah oh yeah they're sent
check for New York's a little looks a
little different it's not that I like I
tell people like it's just I'm so
creative that it's not that I'm like
PTSD I'm skipping it's so much for my
[ __ ] head to take in I'm just like I
need to like look look I need to see it
[ __ ] everything that's going on I was
at Time Square you should see the video
just like things I see on the site I
couldn't let it go brother I live here I
get it like it's what happens when you
live in the vortex you start like really
get into a crazy place because now it's
like you know it's almost like a hard
drug or anything else like now I'm like
I got him like now New York feels that
weirdly slow to me and I'm just like
[ __ ] [ __ ] I need to move to like China
or something you know yeah Thailand
stuff it's just I'm glad you guys came
through as well yeah it's fun day night
nice to spend some time to get into ways
like to line up all the yeah last night
been one of the fans goes yeah I used to
work in New York used to sit up on that
things have been ocular so much he close
your [ __ ] thing across most of the nagas
creeping I was just squishing my bare
white ass against the window for like 10
minutes yeah like he's gonna see it
eventually you have a nice cute little
butt yeah yeah yeah I get it I get it I
get it
probably thinking it's terrible I love
it guys thanks for coming through okay
hit me any to let me know how can be
helped yeah I do
it's nice huh yeah you know what sucks
what not only the amount that I pay but
my [ __ ] number changed yeah why I got
out there and you had to like do
something yeah yeah a little too crazy
yeah and so photo right here yeah
awesome thank you you're welcome yeah
check can you take one industry
[Music]